[Applause]
i've seen so many previously ons now
that i'm genuinely starting to feel
emotions like rage and anger and you
know how we process emotions over here
at tv sins blip i mean good on the
pyramid builders for thinking about the
future needs of a tiny god funko pop
collection in minimalistically appealing
oil lamp cubicles can't believe we
haven't mentioned this already but
opening credits for moon night does not
contain a moon night the trek drove over
the top of the dune this close to leyla
and mark and didn't see them that's
almost as ridiculous as layla somehow
spotting ammunition in the back of the
truck as it speeds by at night
but whatever you do make sure you do not
check inside the truck just around okay
there's no chance she went in there so
don't even bother
oh come on marvel it's not like anyone
believes you'd kill off your main
character with only a few episodes
remaining
a flare is essentially a stick of fire
and fire alone would not be enough to
set off this ammunition especially this
quickly and if the ammunition were this
readily flammable it shouldn't have been
left uncovered like this so uh sin
either way suckers
you guys made a deal
that he would just disappear from my
life i hadn't
hadn't disappeared from your life
already stephen would be [ __ ] brutal
at tv sins ian survives this
suit was his best feature wasn't it
judging a mark by its cover these bullet
holes in the windshield do not match the
pattern of these bullet holes in the
same windshield this high and mighty
goat
i guess believing anything that comes
out your mouth just shows what a plonker
i am stephen's calling himself a dick
for believing mark while simultaneously
being mark so now there are two bloggers
plonking themselves and what you don't
know is this is now evolved to what the
british call a union jack don't look it
up i've been in situations like this
before
so have i it's the same body isn't it
muscle memory in that steven is
expecting to i still know kung fu his
way through a small army of machine
gunning goons after only yesterday
objecting to even being part of any of
this you smell like him i'll take things
that sound romantic but are actually
pretty [ __ ] creepy for two cents
please
down okay first
before i belay thank you what's belay i
still can't tell when you're joking or
not as a general rule of thumb anytime
you know that the person you are rock
climbing slash abseiling with is
currently presenting with a personality
that you've only just met and here on
the side of not kidding just to avoid
any unnecessary confusion or broken
limbs and such also what exactly is she
belaying when she gets down there unless
she's planning on immediately climbing
back out the belaying's done and it
certainly isn't for steven's benefit as
evidenced by his rather abrupt
belay-less landing also also if layla is
lacking this very basic concept i think
it's in steven's best interest to delay
the belay and say hey you okay before
repelling down and breaking all of the
legs but i'm likely belaboring the point
at this stage are you okay
he fell from a great height directly
down into a tomb he should not be aces
if they just sprang to life right now
and asked me a riddle for passage i'd
i'd be thrilled i should myself but i'd
be thrilled
steven continues to be a bloody joy to
him it was a dream
worth dying for
and he did blip it's amazed
it's amazing look let's leave the word
play to the self-professed expert shall
we toot and count moon knight this whole
structure
is a symbol [ __ ] you dude i'm not mine
for a second that he's already been able
to piece together an aerial view of the
caves just based on walking through them
for a few minutes there are six paths
six pass seems important when they begin
to lay out the whole horus's eye thing
but the symbol of the eye doesn't have
six intersecting paths so when they
decide on the tongue path how do they
confidently decipher which of the six
pass represents the tongue so what
you think it's a map i mean to be more
accurate this is a conveniently recalled
symbol suddenly drawn on a conveniently
reflective table that somehow very
quickly became a convenient map a
hexahed car sorcerers of their time
fortunately for us steven's knowledge of
egyptology only stretches to the point
where we the audience need something
explaining hey
you go me yeah unnecessarily splitting
the party i guess i've never come across
an ominous gaping cavern before but if i
did and i were being chased by an undead
murder mummy would i stop to investigate
the depths of the pit with a flare no no
no i would sh myself while navigating
the fastest route out haha yes because
the first thing you do after realizing
the holes in the wall allow dead arms to
jut through is to turn your back on the
wall with the holes you know the
momentum should have carried her to the
bottom of the pit i know the momentum
should have carried her to the bottom of
the pit but someone on the writing team
forgot also at some point these oh no
they died fake outs are resolved so
quickly you're left wondering why bother
no one believes she actually fell to her
death here and even if we did we're only
allowed to sit with that suspense for
like eight seconds oh
you kissed her this is what is important
to mark right now everyone's in danger
and he's feeling the need to start a
pissing contest with himself i think
we're looking
at the long lost tomb
[Music]
of alexander the great oh
huh so why don't you just
go ahead good thing both these two came
miced up so they could hear each other
speaking very softly across this not in
substantial distance floor is yours the
floor may be harrows but the walls are
the mummy killer's walls so stop leaning
on it everything inside me is like
screaming not to open this thing
everything apart from the only actual
voice inside him which is ironically
telling him to open it this symbol of a
waiter serving a piping hot plate of
three flaming hot dogs so what do you
think i think it's super convenient that
alexander was great enough to line his
loot in shiny reflective material that
allowed this reflective conversation to
continue sir
we just found another way harrowing his
goons had a huge head start over steven
and layla and yet they still managed to
find ahmet's tomb last they should have
been able to swarm through this place
just through sheer numbers alone the
scare pointed directly down to ahmet's
tomb so why would it point to the
entrance and not over the actual
location of amitsuhapti seems like
there's a nice opening that leads
outside right here so ride that shaft
all the way down to the good stuff man
i'm talking to mark
well that was easy for once but why how
did he die unless this conversation
leads to the revelation that on the
night of her father's death mark also
found a secret exit out of the lost tomb
of alexander the great can we please put
a pin in it until after they've escaped
the angry men with the guns come on
bringing a ceremonial axe thing to a
gunfight
oof we're still bringing your chest to a
gunfight
oh come on marvel it's not like anyone
believes you'd actually kill off your
main character with only a few episodes
remaining it's pretty clear from this
angle that mark's falling down a flight
of stairs before hitting the water but
then he doesn't i can't save anyone who
won't save themselves but he doesn't
care about redemption or second chances
his whole deal is stopping people before
they even have a chance to redeem
themselves or before they even realize
they have something that requires
redemption your doctor
imagine getting the call from marvel
that your cast is steven grant and moon
knight and it's this role instead of
what we've been seeing the past three
episodes this is beautiful
very impressive o
m
g
what is up with the ratio of icing to
sponge on this cupcake i took the
liberty of borrowing the film you
brought my actual sex tape how many
times did you say you've seen that movie
despite all parental warnings enough
times to make him go blind apparently
this moment between harrow and his
assistants carries on for us after mark
runs away if this is all in mark's head
why would anything outside of mark's
perspective persist just in case they
never answer this question i'm going to
send it now and ask for some goodness
later whatever [ __ ] the sarcophagus
says that may or may not be important
but i don't have time to crack the code
[Applause]
i'm not sure what the [ __ ] is going on
but this moment clearly represents a
person trying to find what makes them
whole i didn't realize how badly i
needed these two characters to be in the
same physical space and the relief on
stephen and mark's faces as they embrace
is something i felt in my soul if i had
one i mean how is this possible i don't
know me either but someone left their
thermos mug and useless lamp here on the
shelf pointing like this must take too
much effort stop it mark just found
steven in a sarcophagus and it was a
pretty great reunion why would he pass
up another one is it because the third
personality inside isn't crying for help
and no the third personality isn't a
spoiler there have been several hints so
far in this upright creepy red container
is confirming all my suspicions anyway a
cent for not opening the obvious reveal
when it is obvious
[Music]
mark and steven do not actually sh
themselves in this scene also marvel did
not release all six episodes at once
forcing me to spend far too much time in
the deep dark holes of the egyptian lady
hippo subreddits also also holy [ __ ]
after that subreddit dive marvel may
have actually killed off a character
with only a few episodes remaining i'll
give one of the sins back just in case
they have the balls to stick to it
when ramsay's destroyed syria that was
an accident
you
are a catastrophe
as
you
wish
steven
wake up
come on
i strongly suggest
that you wake the [ __ ] up
you're only supposed to blow the bloody
doors off we were somewhere around
barstow on the edge of the desert
when the drugs began to take hold you
guys made a deal
that he would just disappear from my
life i hadn't
hadn't disappeared from your life
already
emotional damage you're in love now
you're in love with my wife this is my
wife
i shall call him squishy and he shall be
mine and he shall be my squishy i'mma
hit fold pop
i like swimming but i'm dangerous
hey you think
god stays in heaven because he too lives
in fear of what he's created